to just Goosebumps everywhere Apple chills what a
freaking episode what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation we are here to watch the
final episode for season one of The Last of Us
joined of course but my handsome friend here at
Andrew the Gordon acre 7-Eleven how are you buddy
I am doing good quick question do you think Abby's
gonna be in this episode no I do not think Abby I
do think so we're going to see at the end who the
intelligent one is and who the dumb one is okay
get ready to feel like a sour bust guys please
go ahead leave a like it means the world to me
for everyone who's been watching with us for these
entire nine weeks I'm just hoping that one day I
could have as great a facial hair as Pedro Pascal
does in this show because today I have a public
service announcement from today's video sponsor
which is manscaped the leaders in the now below
the waist grooming now have beard products and
they've also enhanced their brand new weed whacker
2.0 so guys and Andrew get ready to use our code
Rejects and at manscape.com and get 20 off plus
free shipping let me tell you why I already use
their products religiously I'm a married man if
I've got a nasty situation downstairs and your
nose my brutally honest wife she's gonna let
me know so while I got a lot of products for
the balls which just make for a very confident
situation not showing all those images makes it
look like I got a medical condition I just take
care of myself as should you I should you but now
they have the beard hedger Pro kit when I opened
the package this morning I got so excited threw
it on my wife's head woke her up in the morning
I said look what I got so they got this cordless
electric beard hedger here's just one reason why
I love it let me let me get my old let me get my
old beard trimmer here it is I've had to resort to
putting the links in a baggie because it's just
a constant mess which one is it I can't find is
this the right Andrew can you get that trash
over there score that put I put Andrew so this
beard hedger Pro comes in this Nifty little case
and you might be wondering like Hey where's all
the links only got one like no they're all right
here adjustable tough on the hair but smooth on
the face they say let's find out baby yeah yeah
get those cheeks Andrew I gotta do a full beard
trim later but thank you Andrew you cleaned up
you cleaned up good boy they also got the latest
weed whacker 2.0 they got improved blades and no
tugging guarantee so I got a deviated septum so
I got this one spot that's really hard to
get Andrew clean that up Andrew yeah yeah
doing man the beard trimmer Pro crate also
comes with a beer shampoo and conditioner
beard oil and beard bomb to moisture style
and Shimmer your new beard the kit also has
three free gifts beard brush comb and scissors
baby and for the classic manscape Thrills they
now have the performance package 4.0 which does
include the weed whacker 2.0 and all the other
lower region products there's a few Brands I've
worked with where I have personally remained a
loyal customer and manscaped is definitely one of
them my wife wouldn't have married me if it wasn't
for manscaped manscapes saved my marriage so guys
but especially Andrew you should get it to get 20
off plus free shipping go to manscape.com use our
promo code Rejects at checkout once again that's
manscape.com use our promo code rejects 20 off
plus free shipping use R code hours I want them
to know we've created other manscape salads
because they're the right tools for the job
oh
oh Ashley Jones is that her yeah it is
her you're right she's pregnant with Ellie
sounds just like love it
oh my God it kind of looks like you know
what I'm thinking right Farmhouse yeah
I know which one you're talking about yeah
oh my God it's so good hearing her voice
I know she's got such an amazing voice
God
oh my God nice
fantastic because they let Ashley
Johnson use the knife he's just
thinking that oh [__] is that Ellie's
knife yeah yeah yeah Ellie's born oh
oh she was dead in her first thought was just
spending time with her yeah Born To Survive
that's an opening right there yeah that's
amazing Ah that's so good to see her oh
it kind of reminded me a little bit of Blade as
well pregnant with Bladen attacked by a vampire
whoa
oh my God it's not your fault we would
delay getting out of his own I she's
hungry I didn't want to nurse her find someone
to bring her up and make sure that she's safe
and I want you to give her this was her knife yeah
only
how long have we known each other
wow so you pick her up right now and then
you kill me oh my goodness oh he's turning
well history with Marlene dates
way back I can't kill you please
I'll have someone else do it
cover her ears
oh
we're in that first episode she was like are
you like my mother or something she was like
a surrogate mother well I found this in there
Beefaroni Chef Boyardee he had a guitar in that RV
oh in fact I was thinking maybe I could
teach you want to learn how to play guitar
Ellie oh yeah poorly that'd be great
I love how he's evolved into being
more outspoken and she's become a
lot more sheltered and closed
off this is what I'm thinking
cut through that building to get around
that stuff find a scratch paper gloves
this time I was thinking we blessed our way
through that Rubble I found some dynamite in
that RV back there really no so we're gonna cut
through that building where had you going didn't I
so good together
if I get you up there you can drop that ladder
down maybe we go through that way game stuff okay
you kind of seem extra quiet today so oh
I'm sorry oh damn you David damn you come on
yes yes
right when she looked I knew it
I wonder if they got a real one
there it is
they had this music with Bill and Frank too
semblance of peace it's all
right can you hurry up come on
it says Pennsylvania Clark Field too in the back
this evening
so [__] cool
well where's she going
so
is it everything you hoped for
deception down
we don't have to do this just go back to
Tommy's we forget about the whole damn thing
I've been through
and when we're done we'll go wherever
you want Tommy's cheap ranch the Moon
follow you anywhere you go oh
but there's no halfway with this
we finished what we started
making Jackson what it is now
makes the choice even more tempting
to just turn around absolutely yeah
thank you
Emmy nominations right
damn they did it no emergency medical camps man
me and one just like this with Sarah oh here we
go let's release the guy who shot and missed well
I gotta hand it to the army people they were way
better at stitching you up than I was it was me
I was the guy who shot and missed I couldn't see
the point anymore and I wasn't scared either I
was ready I went to pull the trigger I flinched
anyway the reason I'm telling you all this
you know why you're telling me all this
yeah I reckon you do so Time
Heals all wounds I guess
it wasn't Titanic ha ha ha
I'm glad that
that didn't work out me too
you probably get going yeah
walk it off walk it off guys I thought
they were gonna do the picture moment
but that made up for it that whole story
was amazing it makes sense that Joel would
want to at least Adept it you know
what I'm in the mood for shitty puns
moon rocks tastes better than Earth rocks
why because they're meteors it's terrible
that was actually good that's a zero out
of ten what did the green grape say to the
purple grape really if you would eat it
does a three out of ten whoa oh whoa whoa
this man and little girl are clearly a threat
's only job was to protect me I still
almost got killed how'd you do it
is over just take me to her I can't
she's being prepped for surgery
it makes normal cordyceps think the cheese
cordyceps it's why she's immune he's going
to remove it from her produce those chemical
Messengers and then we can give it to everyone
he thinks it could be a cure Joel oh
boy cordyceps grows inside the brain
it does we didn't tell her we didn't
cause her any fear there won't be any
pain no you take me to her you take me to
her right now please you don't understand
they do damn I was there when she was
born yeah I promised so I do understand
[__] I have no other choice
I do
he tries anything shoot him
man their behave so cold this
Hospital looks exactly the same
I didn't hear anyone say stop which way downstairs
the [__] are you doing keep
walking instead keep walking
oh
where is she I don't have time for this oh
I got goosebumps into heaven
nicely done
is in Terminator mode right now
I love this music yeah and I like how it's
over drawing with the oldest
found design noises right now
oh he's gotta put them all down yeah
oh
oh here's the music it's my
favorite music in the game
wow
oh my God it's the room oh
Recreation 101.
wow they really captured this like a descent
I'm a hooker how did you get in here oh it's
them I won't let you take her oh my gosh
oh no
uh the reason they focus on him yup
[__] okay
the luck of conflict in his
choice can't keep her safe forever
no matter how hard you try how long till she's
torn apart by infected or murdered by Raiders
she lives in a broken world
that you could have saved
so what would she decide because I
think she'd want to do what's right
do you know it even after what
you've done we can still find a way
I heard like how we cradled Sarah
yeah exactly gun pointed at him
and everything yeah we're running
some tests on you and some others
turns out there's a whole lot more like you
people that are immune dozens of them the
doctors they couldn't make any of it work
they've actually
they've stopped looking for a cure
jeez the people hurt yes Marlene okay
okay I'm taking this home
I'm sorry
damn the parallels from the
first episode of this one
you just come after her
does not get enough credit for his
music I think the show does a better
job because of the shorter time frame too
it's easier to hone in on the parallels
between the first episode and the last one
because the game does it sure but it's it's
it's more apparent here probably about a
five hour hike we can manage that remember
see the conflict in Ellie well Sarah and I used to
hike like this all the time she would have liked
you not to say you're two of you are the same
definitely different kids well she was a lot more
I want to say girly and I'm not saying that
you're not girly I'm not you're also white early
do you know why I think she'd like you why
because you're funny anyway I bet you would
have liked her back yeah but I wouldn't
that the rules have switched
that's great this is freaking great
how much further now it's
great visual language man
back in Kansas City you asked me
about the first time I killed someone
Riley she got bit too we didn't
know what to do and she says you
can just wait it out feel poetic
and just lose our minds together
and then she did and I had to
she was the first to die and then it was
Tess and then Sam that's not on you I know
it look sometimes things don't work out
the way we hope but if you just keep going
you find something new to fight
for maybe that's not what you mean
swear to me that everything you
said about the fireflies is true
I swear
okay
same music as the ending of the game
yeah dude just Goosebumps everywhere
Apple chills breaking out dude
what a freaking episode wow
yeah seriously yeah they uh they did it the best
video game adaptation is here yeah they did it
they stuck in the landing it's interesting Bill
Ramsey said this is going to be a very okay sorry
sorry go ahead okay I thought I thought they said
the surge's name was Darren aronovsky just drive
like really um well obviously I was right that
Abby wasn't going to be and you said she was so
you were wrong um but [__] all right normally I
just let this play out in real time but I want to
play it a little bit earlier so that way Andrew
gets the credit he deserves before I continue on
I was technically right Abby was in this episode
just not that Abby we were thinking of look at the
cast right there look at the nurses do you see a
name on there Greg Laura Bailey that is the voice
of Abby oh [__] obviously too they they kept
his face covered because they're obviously gonna
have a different actor as well we don't know
that yes I do I know we don't know that but I
found Bella Ramsay's comment too very interesting
she said last week that this episode is going to
be very divisive for people I don't know if she
was trying to throw off but I I mean at least for
gamers I don't see why this episode would be
divisive it was pretty much in line with the
the exactly what happened in the game for the
most part and obviously we got a little more
expansion on uh Anna and Marlene's relationship
because the only thing we had gotten in the video
game from that was some uh when you're searching
the hospital in the game you find some recordings
and you get to hear a little bit about that
backstory but actually seeing it play out and
of course getting to see the great Ashley Johnson
who's got such a distinctive and incredible voice
and watching what she had to go through and then
seeing the knife at her neck I mean that was so
freaking like tragic having a break that's the
most tragic way to have I mean to have a baby
like that and that's insane and I just thought in
the limited amount of screen time that Ashley gave
us I imagine doing that with a clicker attacking
you on top of a bus yeah and that would be more
tragic yeah seriously but use your imagination
right no but it was I was so glad that they were
able to get Ashley Johnson Troy Baker and uh when
we got uh uh as Perry what's his name Jeffrey uh
Pierce and that was great to uh get all three
of them in I'm so glad Unfortunately they all
got uh epic deaths of course but yeah no I mean it
was great to get the original cast back but this
episode I I don't know this might be my favorite
episode of the Season it was it was pretty it was
pretty close it's it's damn perfect and notice
I know you're gonna make some jokes or nothing
defending yourself again I didn't complain about a
specific action sequence in the tunnel before you
know with infected which I freaking love that
sequence in the uh the game when you're about
to get a catch up with the fireflies and you you
know you get into that whole water sequence I'm
not complaining that that was in here I actually
think that was smart to cut it in this one it's
not action storytelling it's not character driven
storytelling in terms of the action don't mind
that they got rid of that there so that's why last
week for the people saying that I was whining and
playing including yourself you know you've been
texting me like dude stop whining every episode
um but I found it I found it interesting
that uh you know you know I had to like
defend myself a little bit there it's like there
was a specific reason why that that bothered me
a little you know it didn't hinder my love for
this show I still love the show but in this case
that's a fun action sequence in the game but I
don't I think it was a smart choice especially
for pacing purposes that they got rid of that
sequence would have been cool visually easy of
course but I didn't mind that they got rid of
it here so sorry that I disappointed you guys
that I didn't whine in that sequence today well
Jeremy Jones said the same thing and I actually
uh understand where you're coming from and I think
a lot of people actually said the same thing too
so yeah don't fret man don't fret no jokes for me
today I'm going to be very serious I want jokes
not today Andrew sorry it's not my style anymore
okay I'm excited that from here on out what people
want is a serious Greg yeah and by the way if
they if those two don't get nominated which
I think it's a it's a guarantee that they will
it's criminal if those daddy Pedro is going to
get that nomination well both of them I think this
was my favorite episode yeah I think this was my
favorite episode for Bella or belly by the way
HBO Max thank you for what you guys proved that
you watch our reactions because we saw on your
Twitter account that you called her belly so
thank you so much yeah yeah HBO Max give credit
where credits due it was the first video this
guy right here was the first one to say I don't
need credit I did not find another video where
they called her belly and all right you can have
the name enjoy guys whatever HBO Max yeah I mean
um I have a couple of things that I thought
would have uh helped enhance this episode a
little bit uh but before uh all my commentary is
overshadowed by those two little things I will
talk about for two minutes I want to show talk
about what I loved about this first uh yeah I I
thought that they absolutely excelled like sure is
it shorter than the game yeah but you know this is
one of those things where you do kind of have to
judge it as a complete package by the end of it
all and by the time you get to the end you know I
I think some of the best storytelling is when you
see the completion of an art and the completion of
how the beginning of the story really mirrors the
end of the story and watching the differences
and what I really loved that they that they
really enhanced more with Joel throughout this
show but it especially hammers it home here
is that because it is a debate in the game of like
did Joel make the right choice people go back and
forth with that some people are there some people
don't even bother with the gray side of the
question there some people are like he absolutely
did they were gonna kill her and the other people
who are like actually I think Joel's the villain
of the story because there was a chance they could
have had to have it have a cure have a vaccine
at least produced to help people out right so
and to me I'm always fascinated by both sides
here to me I think about the character and I'm
like it makes sense that this character would
make this choice and what I thought that they
really really nailed uh when it came to Joel with
showing just how destroyed he is and and all the
psychological trauma he's had to endure that when
he's going up the hill with Ellie at the very end
here and talking about like you would have liked
Sarah and here's why there was like as touching
as it is there was this other quality in my
brain and heart I was like there's something
else so semi-disturbing about this because this
guy is so like messed up like so destroyed that
he will commit the the most heinous darkest most
brutal violent acts to live in this fantasy of
I have a daughter now like she's my daughter and
and look we're gonna have this uh a life of light
from here on out and the second she starts to
try to open up about like tests being on her
uh uh like or something that weighs on Ellie it's
like he's just no don't think about that you know
like no stop I don't you don't just don't feel
don't feel in this apartment things are going to
be good like that's a lot of the intent about
it so maybe disturbing is too harsh of a word
it's just you could see so much of wow a lot of
these choices he made is because of unresolved
issues that this that this guy really has and and
stuff like that carries over with into the second
game and thematically wise I think Pedro Pascal
just absolutely killed it here because I find
his version of Joel you know like if you compare
to what Troy Baker did Troy Baker's was perhaps
more hardened and tougher uh I find what he did
here more Disturbed like this feels like a more
like Joel in the game is in still a lot of ways
is still like kind of a fantasy art type kind
of cool guy that any guy with emotional pain
would love to be that kind of dude like oh man
I wish you could be that cool of a guy even if
I had that mess of bull I would love to be John
Wick like who wouldn't want to be right and here
it's like this just feels like a truly Disturbed
human being like this every every ounce of
him is the way they did the parallel of how
he had a he had his daughter in his hands at
the beginning Sarah and a gun pointed at him
bam did Soldier shot uh at him and killed his
daughter and then here the soldier of firefly
you know Marlene she lowers her weapon you know
gives him the choice and he makes the choice to
execute her and he commits this act of violence
in in the most cold way but then when he's around
Ellie he's all smiles and open you know and I
love it I I think the performance is excellent and
um watching too like if you remember that second
episode when they're looking at what's it called
during their embossing the bell tower uh oh
uh the capital the capital building yeah and
then everything you you hoped it would be when
they're looking at the you know they have that
nice moment there of course with the giraffe
which is awesome great to see that adapted but
when they're when they're looking at Jackson and
and in that framing we've seen in the show how
they have switched roles how Joel has become a
lot more like and L is much more stuff yeah and
then in that moment too when they are looking
at the Capitol building in the second episode
Ellie's the one with the hopeful look and where
their position and frame is different and then
they switch sides here and I love the visual
language of how they have switched sides I
thought this was expertly done and you know in in
the when you're playing as Joel in the game when
he's messing up all the Firefly soldiers of course
I'm there on Joel's side I'm not like what am I
doing I'm like you're gonna kill Ellie of course
this is ridiculous he's lying he was saying what
am I doing what am I doing I keep moving forward
and pressing x uh that when when you're playing
as Joel there yeah and here they've made it more
of a conflict of a choice of what's happened like
they're not glorifying this violence it's not
a like go get him Joel it's not a go mess them
up and go rescue Ellie moment at least the way
some people might still be feeling that way but
I think in the way the the filmmakers decided to
execute that it it just felt like a descent the
entire time and how you were pointing out with
like how the music and the sound like things
were just getting drowned out and he was just
becoming cold as the violence progressed and
I loved how it if it doesn't it doesn't glorify
the act it doesn't glorify the violence at that
moment it could have easily just been a badass
moment with Joel in a lot of ways not that the
game does that but an adaptation that goes wrong
could have done that but I love how they just
hammered it home like I was so impressed with
what they decided to do here uh I have nothing
but praise for this other than one little thing
and what was that one little thing because the
the thing that makes the debate of did Joel
make the right choice or not very strong
is the fact about when you're in the world of the
game at least like here in the show I'm like man
come on it's pretty obvious man like say belly
but especially because the fireflies are are just
they're so cold like even they feel colder here in
this show than they did in the game even Marlene
is like obvious like I loved the choice that they
did with I don't know I want to give you a chance
to talk about that because I love the choice that
they did with to bring Marlene in the beginning
here to make this conflict even harder for her so
you see that she's not just a cold-hearted [__]
about the entire thing right um but the fire they
did they did such a good job on humanizing other
camps throughout this series but they just make
they just block this into Joel's perspective here
so you just only see the fireflies as being so
cold and the other part is is what makes it so con
uh such a con which I like that choice but what
makes it such a conflict is the fact that at least
in the game every moment even when you go inside a
building or whatever you're just afraid a clicker
or an infected is around the corner or whatever
you just see how at any moment like how necessary
the attempt for a cure is and here because of the
fact that the the infector was kind of dialed back
I would I it made it even easier for me to it made
it even easier for me to be swayed to the side of
Joe yeah just yeah just save Ellie there's doesn't
seem like the infected our that big of a pro like
they're a problem but they're not they don't
look like that that bad in this world it seems
like that's something they can still um get under
control in some way yeah that's the thing of why I
think the complaint that some people have about
a lack of infected is it just feels like chaos
in the game and it feels there's no way you can
prevent this or stop this or or contain it whereas
here it's like I feel like there's a way we can uh
figure out how to contain this a little bit right
yeah no I get what you're saying you're saying a
lot more in the game it was more even though again
we're still on Joel's side there's a lot more of a
gray area then I don't know just it's Joel Sevilla
like it's it's a lot more it's a lot more easier
of a choice here in terms of like because of the
effect it's been like you said dialed back so
much so it's a it's a lot more Simple Choice and
before I continue on I was technically right Abby
was in this episode just not that happy we were
thinking of look at the cast right there look
at the nurses do you see a name on there Greg
Laura Bailey that is the voice of Abby oh [__]
so uh in the comments section I'm sure people
who have not reached this point are gonna go
crazy in the comments in front of us I noticed
it after I started after I finished I was like
I'm gonna let Greg do his whole thing and then
I'm gonna mention this I'm sure in the comments
section we're gonna hear one of the nurses that
is Abby well clearly you didn't get to this point
because now we're mentioning it it's hard to tell
when people are wearing masks to tell you know who
who the actor actually that's a cameo yeah no I
thought that was to put her as a cameo in that
scene too right with the doctor oh yeah can we
talk spoilers yet or no no no spoilers okay okay
uh but yes I agree putting her in that scene yeah
all the scenes these games people will play the
second game no one yeah the people who played like
that was the perfect scene yeah we don't need to
say why yeah I'm sure she'll get another Cameo too
in part two is or in season two rather but uh no I
mean I I hear what you're saying and it's hard for
me to argue because the clickers were so dialed
back yeah so I I totally get where you're coming
from in regards to that um but yeah I mean but
still again because the the emotional conflict
is is so strong between Pedro Pascal or rather
with Joel and Ellie it again it's like he said
it's easy to get on the side of Joel but I just
thought that it's more of a wish and I want to
clarify no no of a wish that would have enhanced
the debate but I'm not exact I'm not like bothered
I have a feeling though and again I'm sure they
knew they had a hit on their show but I I do
appreciate the fact and that they focused more on
the characters than the action beats because if I
like I like I've always said and even in the last
episode where I had my complaining in my whining
about that one sequence that was that was gone if
I had to make a choice between good like nailing
the characters or nailing the action sequence
it's not even close like I want I want I want
good characters I mean yeah the action sequences
are a wish list for me but if you can nail like
the characters and obviously know the relationship
between Joel and Ellie they like I mean you heard
Greg at the end of the reaction this is the best
video game at adaptation of all time at least
in our subjective Minds so they nailed it from
there part of the video game adaptation would be
better like come on yeah there's no other way I am
thinking though possibly and again I'm hoping they
continue this trend in season two and I I've heard
a lot of people saying that Craig mazzin Mason
however you say his last name sorry if I butchered
it uh he did say that uh season two uh for part
two is going to be split up into two seasons is
what I've been hearing I don't know if you've
seen those those comments it makes sense you can't
just in no way yeah yeah the game is forever so
um yeah so I mean I am hope again if I have to
choose one again still keep nailing the characters
down keep doing what you're doing I am hoping
though now that they've seen even though again
they knew they had a hit on their hands with this
show now they know they're in the stratosphere in
terms of hits yeah so I'm hoping that we we do
get more on the infected side in terms of the
action sequences in the next season just just
to feel that Threat Level more to to pay off
in terms of what you're talking about in terms of
like you know it's not all black and white there
are some gray areas so I I totally understand
and you are very validated in my opinion what
you're saying in regards to I still feel the same
way even in the game I'm still rooting for Joel
because my whole thing is this I mean obviously
we've the whole in the video game everything is
from Joel and Ellie's perspective so of course
we're gonna I mean for the most part you're gonna
root for Joel yeah obviously there's going to be
people inside well hey like what about everyone
else like they deserve to be you know uh have the
the vaccine so that they can't get infected from
the current infected because you can't cure the
people who are already infected but you can at
least protect yourself from being infected in the
current world I get that side of the argument even
in the video game but again we're so invested
in these characters in the video game and you
know Joel like he's not losing another daughter
that's just that's not happening so but they do
play that interesting question of did Joel make
the right decision or not in the game word here
again because it's dialed back it's a lot simpler
of a choice is what you're saying so no I mean
I I get what you're saying it's I I'm trying to
find a way to argue with you but because it was
dialed back so much but again I'm still glad of
the choice Joel me because again we don't know
much about the even in the video game you don't
know too much about the fireflies I mean yeah
Marlene seems like a a good character I mean from
what we know and obviously I'm glad they expanded
upon her and Anna in the in the beginning and also
too they what they didn't show in the video game
after she had Joel escorted out you didn't get
that moment of seeing the pain in her eyes and
seeing the tear coming down so I thought that was
a great touch that they added here in the show
but other than that we really don't know much
about them even in the video game so if they
did get that cure in the vaccine who are they
going to selectively use it are they going to
be authoritarians with how they use like we don't
know exactly how they would have used it yeah so
that's why I was more on the side of Joel because
I have no idea who these people are what they're
going to do with it a big part of it also comes
down to that they didn't give Ellie a choice
that was the shitty part yes and I mean they they
really drive that home even more outside yeah they
drive that home here too especially but the fact
that they robbed her of a choice is the messed
up part like everyone's deciding for her yes and
they're like don't worry she doesn't know there's
gonna be no trauma and they they should have
let her decide and that becomes the thing that
I won't talk about like I should really call
myself yeah um yeah they should have gave
her a choice but I think the the very uh the
introduction to to explain yeah kind of like
a blade situation as you pointed out of like
why couldn't this vampire walk in the day yeah
that's that is a great call on what went down
uh getting Ashley Johnson back who you know I
it's really like Ellie's my favorite video game
character me too so it's not even close so yeah
like to me just like even hearing her even though
she's not fully doing the like her voice not too
far off in the Ashley her actual Ashley Johnson
voice yeah yeah I I don't even know if I would
say it's entirely different but like like Troy
Baker's actual voice is very is definitely doing
a jewel voice right yeah for sure um but you know
seeing her there and then seeing that the the kind
of life that Ellie was born into and of course
hammering home with Marlene that much further
does give you that weight of because because
it's interesting like in the show Marlene plays
his scene so much colder when she's talking when
she's confronting Joel but in the game I don't
feel she's as that cold in the actual game but
because you got that earlier scene you do see
that that connection yeah that she does have of
like this is everyone has to make a sacrifice
here for something bigger so I think that was
a great opening scene to have and and to know
and the way that you like catch up with Ellie in
that moment too and it does cut to her it's like
like it felt very it felt very purposeful
to me when Marlene says cover her ears
as if like she's just a baby like it more like
she's a baby she's not gonna remember any of
this you know so like she's just bored but but
it says cover her ears and then bam Ellie the
baby starts to burst into tears so you do
get the sense that there is some type of
subconscious resin like memory that lingers in the
back maybe something that Ellie doesn't obviously
doesn't clearly remember but has affected her in
some way even though it was moments after she was
born that this memory is somehow still in her
brain somewhere that has defined her along the
way yeah and the reason also too I agree with
what you said and the reason too I also I mean
I've obviously I've praised belly all season long
but I think the reason this episode was one of my
favorites and obviously of course they're doing
from the video game but what Bella Ramsay was able
to do in this episode just immediately when we see
her just showing how traumatized she is by what
David by what she had gone through with David and
how I mentioned it in the last episode like a part
of her soul and so much rage has been pent up into
Ellie which we might possibly see you later don't
want to get in spoilers but again just just seeing
how traumatized she is because you gotta remember
I mean yes it's been dialed back she is lives in a
world where she is hunted by clickers infected and
hunters and Raiders and all this stuff I mean she
sees some messed up stuff but it took a preacher
dude that wanted to make her her pet and and was a
pedophile that really struck a chord with her and
like traumatized her like beyond belief and I just
saw it Bella Ramsay like and you can look at these
words on a page and say yeah traumatized the way
she was able to emote and and express that through
her body language through her facial expressions
I really I mean again just my subjective opinion
she was fantastic all season I loved every episode
she was in she just got better every episode yeah
but she really stood like above The Fray in this
I mean Pedro Pascal was so freaking good in this
episode too but she was on another level for me
in this episode like she rose up to the to Kingdom
come in this episode she was so freaking good like
I just I felt every second like of how traumatized
she was just it from the beginning to just when
she couldn't hear jokes like what it just again
I know it's from the game but again it's it's what
Bella Ramsey was able to do in her performance in
this episode body language facial expression wise
just really impressive I'm just so impressed well
there's a lot of things about that giraffe scene
that I've heard people I mean I haven't really
heard anyone talk about it but I can I could
fathom that there's a lot of ways to sort of
interpret that moment and to me you know there's
such a loss of Innocence that has occurred with
Ellie uh based off the events of like what we saw
with David and such and who she's turned into that
you know you see this childlike innocence come
back by looking at something that just seems so
pure like they're just giraffes being how giraffes
are in this really messed up world they're not
looking around the the environments going like
what happened to our city and the economy and the
world and to be like they're just being giraffes
so they're they're still there's a there's still
a family of giraffes they're gonna live on like
there's there's such a purity to it and then it
brings out this childlike Wonder within Ellie
like there is an innocence that is regained in
that moment and that's what's heartbreaking about
it at the same time when you're seeing how they
smile because there's so much hurt underneath
that smile at the same time you know yeah no
definitely I also had two a weird visual parallel
too like when you know when the infected when
the runners or the stalkers when they you know
when the quarter steps come out of their mouth
and they're trying to infect you obviously you
have to stay away from it but when the giraffe
was sticking its tongue out and she was able to
actually touch it it was like I I was getting
some visual callback like no this is an innocent
animal that you can pet it you can you and let
it lick you with its tongue so I thought that
was really interesting that they really focused
on that because I don't remember them the video
game where you actually saw the giraffe's tongue
come out like that I don't remember the thing in
the game about Joel I'm trying to unlive himself
yeah that I don't remember any of that
at all I remember that scene and then I
don't remember that conversation happening and I
think that that is a v that to me is a necessary
addition absolutely like that is so there's some
there's like qualities you know like nice addition
um better Edition and then there's necessary
Edition because to me I have always wondered
that like how did this guy just not try to
attempt this at one point because come on
like after everything you've been through it all
you're moping around of course this guy would at
some point right would have had to have attempted
that so I thought like then having a whole detail
to that story like something that they did
set up one I want to say that third episode
um when she's talking about the scar in his
head and then two explain that yeah but there
was something that that made him Flinch that made
him go I guess I guess I just have to survive and
endure endure and survive right and then he's
telling the story to Ellie and it's like this
is my purpose you yeah this is why I'm still here
I thought it was I thought acknowledging that all
that was so to me I'm like thank you for saying
that because this is a conversation I've been like
having with myself like how did Joel never attempt
this and in the game and we can talk about this
because it's from the first game it's not from
the second game in that moment in the video game
Ellie gives Ellie gives Joel a picture that the
whole scene was emitted in you know so when Joel
goes to visit Tommy at the the power plant uh
that we didn't get to see in the show but in
the game he shows him the picture because he went
back to Texas back to their house and they showed
him a picture of Joel and Sarah together where
she was playing soccer and they've just had a
happy moment it was like right before outbreak
and we see that Tommy is trying to give Joel
that picture and he doesn't want it and then we
see that Ellie snat we didn't see Ellie snatch
it but in the background she did snatch it and
then in that moment in the game she gives it to
uh to Joel to just make him feel better in the
moment but I thought they were going to go that
route but I I and I still would have loved that
but I really like this too it was so freaking
well done like it was just executed so perfectly
it was such a beautiful addition and then again
just like you said the the whole line of like I I
did feel that way and basically in subtext still
I met you and I just thought the line was
so beautifully delivered and again the way
belly just reacted to it was just like chef's
kiss so perfect I mean they're just so good
together those two like you guys can understand
too it's more than just actors for the game who
do The Voice work like they're they're mokey like
we keep saying that but it is they are mocaps so
it is they are doing the whole performance yeah
and those are our iconic performances they are
they are literally iconic so for them to step into
this different medium of live action and then to
make it their own where I just stop comparing the
way delivery is done yeah I just like I don't even
think about it sometimes I'm like oh they remember
that line from the game but I'm so invested in
what they're doing is very impressive you know
it's a challenge that a lot of play actors often
have and to see that they've done it here is
incredible I thought they were excellent I think
they both desert reminisce another thing I don't
think it's talked about in night because it's not
as we point out like something here or there I
think the way this show is shot is great like it
just looks beautiful it's a beautiful looking show
that doesn't depending on the episode sometimes
they do decide to go like let's make this look
like [__] popping you know but more often than
not they just make they while there's like a lot
of cool visual flourishes they still never lose
sight of we want this to feel real at the same
time uh I think they did an excellent job there
everything on the technical department and yeah
sure once in a while you could see like let's go
earlier greens go like the same with the Giraffe
you're like the green screen what's going on here
um but more often than not I don't even notice it
more often than that like I only notice it really
when I'm like okay I could see like a little thing
here or there that guy can tell like or sometimes
your subconscious eye can just see it but most of
the time like the way they've brought a lot of the
destruction the overgrown weeds and the grass and
then the rubble uh all that is excellent and the
fact that they've chosen specific key sequences
uh for their sets to completely resemble like
the hospital like we're gonna link this look
exactly like how it was in the game and but
we're not just gonna show it off we want there
to really be a specific mood and emotion like
everything every choice even if it aesthetically
harkened back to the game seemed like they would
put it in there if there was an emotional purpose
to serve it and I think that's the best way you
can do this adaptation they did it look at all
these looks like Indian people who worked on this
uh as a digital artist for this show um they were
amazing yeah this is a this is this was uh this
is an incredible experience and I'm so happy with
it uh they like a lot of times you think you see
this with a lot of Marvel shows too where you're
like this is good but they man they dropped the
like they're the Lasting Impression me can mean
so much that can mean we can sometimes outweigh
the entire experience leading up to it but but if
you nail that finale like poof man like they they
did it and none of these episodes to do and uh
I could have gone for longer uh I I can't wait
for season two the non-controversy season I can't
always wait for that [__] you guys have if you
haven't played if you don't know what happens
in that game you are not ready for the kind of
[__] is coming your way yeah because if if this
faithfulness is anything of a testament to like
wow we want to honor the game um I I'm like it's
gonna be a very different Journey because it's
season two and again without getting into spoilers
they have foreshadowed and set the seeds in place
that yeah for people who have played the game of
part two we know what's coming I mean obviously
I'm sure they're going to take Liberties like
they did in this one with expanding certain
moments cutting out certain things and doing that
kind of stuff but they even enhanced like they
gave us an extra shot in that hospital thing that
we like oh God I don't want to point it out yes I
know what you're talking about that but like they
lingered on a specific dead body for a reason yep
and I was like man they're they are setting it up
lingered on that [__] linger is the key word so
um guys what did you think about the finale have
you already bought a last of a shirt that's the
most important thing um follow Andrew igor711 on
Instagram and Twitter uh right now he's getting
so many followers mainly from the jabby COA
side of things and I hate that I loathe it
with a passion a fury in me so can you guys
please go follow him from the real rejects
Camp I hate it I hate it so much I hate you I
hate him I hate most people I kind of like my
wife she's okay she's she's great she gets a
pass I love her unconditionally do I like her
though you know because she's my job uh and uh
follow us on patreon and um let's do a patreon
Michael B Michael B right now I know you are
slaving away as well it's chopping editing
to get your last of us reaction up here on the
channel Omni media him and I just did a reaction
together for the movie called knock at the cabin
uh he's one of my favorite people I love talking
with this guy uh he's a true Talent a real Gem
and uh if you guys like reaction videos if you
like reactors but great commentary Michael
B omnimedia he is the channel to go to way
better than this term I suck I'm a whiner or
anything he's at the jabby COA side of things
that's where that's where the recycling bin goes
all all you people or what's it called now
I don't even know the name of it oh my God
you know you're desperately you
gotta change your name like that
come on defend your new family you're gonna
say you're desperate sex when you gotta find
me on the the channel but no you were here first
I don't have friends I got family you were here
first Andrew yeah all I know is buried me I did I
did I did I love you I love you both of you guys
I'm not picking aside so I'll let you I'll let you
two do you mean if there was a side you wouldn't
pick the one you met the one who brought you to
YouTube I'll save that comment for off camera
I'm gonna bring that man in this room and
we're gonna have this private conversation
on camera we're gonna be like come here boy come
here come here oh yeah Michael B go follow him